Hi!
We have learned in the previous short that
most CNNs do not actually compute convolutions,
but the cross-correlation instead.
Why should we care?
We should care if we want to answer this follow-up
Quiz question on this.
Now seriously, in our last short we already
mentioned a reason: porting models from one
library using the cross-correlation to another
one using the convolution (or vice-versa),
can be a headache without knowing that learned
kernels are rotated by 180 degrees.
Otherwise, while many of the convolution properties
are kept, the commutativity of the convolution
is lost, since we also lost the kernel flipping
in the convolution that was ensuring commutativity.
Ms. Coffee Bean just wrote a mini example
down for you.
Pause the video if needed.
Admittedly losing commutativity by replacing
convolutions through cross-correlations is
nothing that bothers Machine Learning people.
While commutativity is important for writing
mathematical proofs, it’s not relevant when
training your CNN.
Okay, bye!